what is going on everybody welcome to
part 11 of our Python with PI QT
tutorial video series in this video
we're gonna be talking about the font
picker built in to PI Q T so this is
just one of the many widgets that will
make your life way easier so let's go
ahead and we're gonna add this to the
home page and we're gonna put it in the
toolbar so after we add here basically
we're gonna do this let's move this down
and then we're gonna come here and
basically we'll keep the same toolbar
actually I'll show you cut something
interesting when we change this so let's
just copy all of that and we'll paste
and we're gonna say instead we're gonna
call this font choice and then we're
gonna say so this is font choice font
choice self dot font choice and font
here and then here this will be setup
font choice like that I'm probably
missing something here besides this so
this one if you recall this one had a
icon and name and obviously self but
instead what we're gonna do is we're
gonna get rid of the icon part and then
we're going to change this to font just
like that so you have font choice font
choice that's good self DUP fun choice
just making sure net missing itself dot
toolbar so what we could do is we can
either get rid of this toolbar like this
and run that so let's go well it's gonna
get angry at us because we haven't
defined this method yet so let's define
that method first so we're going to come
down here define font choice and font
choice we just need to pass self and
what we're gonna do is we run basically
it's this dialog so we're gonna say
basically font and valid so this returns
two
or returns to variables basically so
it's gonna be QT GUI dot Q font dialog
dot get font so this is a font dialog
and we want to go ahead and get the font
so it's gonna pop up both and then we're
just gonna ask if valid what do we want
to do we're gonna say self dot style
choice dot set fine fine okay
so that's gonna what it's going to do is
it's going to if valid self that style
choice at font of line should be uh show
us here and it will be basically here so
when this goes to create that label that
we created in the previous video what
it's going to do is it's going to use
the font that we choose so that font
will change and you'll see what I mean
in a bit when we change it so now we've
got font choice coming back up to the
very very top here we've got self-taught
toolbar and all that let's go ahead and
run this really quick
and we can see ok so we've got some
choices here and this is all part of the
same toolbar so if we moved it over here
font and the little baby come with us
whereas what if what if what if we close
this and instead we said self-taught
toolbar and we add kind of like this
other you know font what happens only at
that well now they're kind of their own
little toolbars so I can with a little
baby over here but font still stays
they're not gonna move on down you know
I can even actually move it over here
right there okay so depending on what
you want you can either make a new
toolbar or you can keep it a part of the
original toolbar it doesn't really
matter I think it's wise to go ahead and
keep the old toolbar but even do what
you want so anyways whenever you click
on it up will pop the font picker and we
can choose all kinds of font here let's
choose something interesting and can we
choose wing-dings we sure can bold that
and put it to 24 right um so now we've
got the massive windows but it's a
little too big to fit in the whole
dimensions that we specified so it's do
this so anyway you can run through this
and keep changing the font of this label
here it doesn't really matter
but this is just a quick example of how
you can actually change fun and what's
cool is that
you can you can pick all kinds of fonts
now can't we awesome
Oh anyway so now you have this awesome
font picker and like sometimes like
these may or may not be useful to you
depends on what your application is of
course but it's certainly nice to have a
font picker at your disposal so this is
the font picker is really just one of
the major things that PI QT is gonna
give to you but there are actually some
other things that we're gonna be talking
about really quickly here there's going
to be the color picker so it's like a
color wheel that you can choose from
also there is like a nice kind of editor
widget calendar widget and trying to
think of anything else that we're gonna
be showing
oh and a file picker so it's a it's a
way that you can find your files open
them close them save them whatever so
stuff like that so anyways that's we're
going to be talking about in the coming
video so stay tuned for that if you have
any questions or comments up to this
point please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time